the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the howdy do y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all social
media uh look if you're watching please
help the show out hit that subscribe I'm
telling you it's a free way to help the
show and it really matters and if you
gotta have more then you gotta check out
the patreon if you didn't see the
episode with Josh Wolf go watch that and
then go subscribe to the patreon it's
called the Honeydew with y'all and it's
your stories and I'm telling you this
[__] it just doesn't stop getting Wilder
it just doesn't every time I hear a
story I'm like I don't know anybody's
gonna out do that and then somebody's
like hey you see how I had this
motorcycle accident lost both my legs
and [__] and I'm [__] in a bag I'm
like oh no but please come on the show
and he did all right it's five bucks a
month you sign up for a year you get
over a month free and you're getting
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right that's it now
you guys know oh also make sure you
subscribe to the crab Feast if you're
looking for a new podcast go check out
an old one it's Audio Only and today's
guest actually did the crab Feast but he
is now here for the first time you guys
know what we do over here we highlight
the low lights and I always say these
are the stories behind the storytellers
and I am very excited to have here today
first time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome big J Oprah so
welcome to the Honeydew big day thank
you for having me thank you for having
me this is something I wanted to do for
a while
um but before we get into whatever you
want to talk about please plug promote
everything
um bigjcomedy.com for all my dates I'm
non-stop on the road so look for a city
near you at bigjcomedy.com uh I do the
bonfire with Dan Soder faction talk
series x7103 uh that's on Monday through
Friday 5 to 7 P.M Eastern and uh Legion
of skanks and Str show both in the guest
digital Network and then my special dog
belly will be coming out April 5th I
believe great so check that out it's
just YouTube free enjoy same thing I'm
doing it's the way to do it I love it I
love it I did not you have uh
you have good like you have a broad like
production knowledge though too uh aside
from just comedy which is important but
that's what it was like the hardest
thing for me like not just being
involved in only like when other people
produce things you just like just show
up and be funny yeah what do you think
the backdrop should be this whatever and
then now it's like you know what do you
think the backdrop should be and it's
like this might be cool and they go okay
that's 14 Grand you're like you know
what yeah you know what no one needs
that you got some towels back there man
yeah when you're playing with like
Comedy Central or Netflix money yeah
it's fine can there be a volcano behind
me like a real semi-orrupting
oh that's [__] great that's the truth
though what's it called again dog belly
dog belly all right it comes out in
April
um look I've wanted to talk to you for a
long time because I know that you uh
were a single dad like myself you have a
daughter like I do I didn't realize you
said she's 20 now and I was like [__] I
told her and I thought which makes me
feel older but I want to talk to you
about that because co-parenting is
challenging quite a bit
um but what's your upbringing what's
your background like what you're from
Philly originally but what was your
family life like your mom and dad split
early my dad split uh my mom dad split
when I was three
he took off off he left yeah he went to
well they fought they had an argument
and he left one night and that was it
and he uh
he went to Florida for a while because
he had family there his family is like a
weird almost story my dad uh
I know he tells it like a little more
dramatic than I think it actually was
but they were Florida his dad
his dad sucked so the mom packed them
all up and moved for some reason to
Philly
married a guy there he was abusive and
kicked the [__] out of everybody and
then they all went back to Florida and
he stayed in Philly and dot dot dot met
my mom
now do you have brothers and sisters huh
do you have brothers and sisters I have
so my mom I'm the only child of my mom
and dad okay my mom has three with my
stepfather okay uh two sisters and a
brother and my dad's got two sons uh in
Ohio with my stepmother
so we're gonna get to that yeah it's
interesting so he left you so yeah so
they've split I mean and he went to
Florida he left he didn't just wasn't
co-parenting
and he came back I mean when I was still
little he definitely came back
um it may have been like six months it
may have been three months could have
been a year I don't remember because I
was too young but when he was back all
my next memory is left my mom and he was
with Kathy my first stepmother
Kathy was great uh she had three kids
also and then that was like the weekends
I was supposed to go there every other
weekend
which got dialed back to uh when he
showed up which wasn't all the time
consistently
and um and that was sort of like the way
it was like throughout the whole thing
like if I didn't you know he forgot
birthdays a lot
but it would take me but it always felt
arbitrary like he kind of had to
and um what's funny though is
as an adult I know I'm drifting on the
story of my fear but as an adult
it is you said you're 50 I'm 45.
I feel sympathy more for like my parents
not my parent my mom didn't really [__]
up much I'd say uh nothing that was
life-changing in any way my dad like I
feel like
sympathy for his [__] ups because
when I left
my uh ex-wife
yo so you were married yeah yeah okay
um when I left my daughter was 12.
and how I was like thank my dad how
freaked out I was that my daughter would
think any feel any way about me as my
dad how I feel about my dad scared the
[__] out of me and it's probably
honestly and it's no disrespect to my
ex-wife she was great it was just we
shouldn't have gotten married you know I
mean I was like
a young fat kid and then for the first
time my life from doing comedy
even if it was uh it's never had in my
life even if it was someone who was
morbidly obese and unattractive to me I
was so insecure that I was anything I'd
be like let's go do it
and uh you know so I wasn't ready for
like a kid marriage but I stayed
wait it was funny when uh
my daughter became again older and I
talked to her about it I was like
because I was surprised that she even
had like the I was blown away that as
tight as I thought we were
she had the classic I thought you left
because of me thing
and she told me she held on to that for
years I was like oh man I go I'm so
happy you told me because I can clear
that up for you quick
I was there about six years longer than
I ever would have been because of you
because I was like if I had a left when
you were like six
it's probably around the time where I
realized I'm like I don't know man this
might not be and my move instead was to
go let's get married but I kind of like
did I didn't really know what the
outcome was gonna be but like
you know if we there wasn't a kid I was
like but if I left
I was bro I was broke
and by that I mean even at the I
consider if you break even at the end of
a month you're broke you know I mean if
you're paying all your bills but you
know you're broke
and I was we were like that and I was
like if I leave
you know I mean now I'm like having you
know I'm just cutting in half the my
household income ultimately
and wherever I can afford to live is not
going to be convenient to get to her
and it's going to be hard and it's
almost
thinking about that gave me sympathy for
my dad in a bit because he just he was
young one so they were 19 when I was
three they were 22. he split my first
stepmother was older than him I didn't
realize how much older because he seemed
he's my dad I didn't see was a 22 year
old kid 23 year old kid
um do you know me I thought he was just
like so always a man yeah even when I
grew up watching guys in the NFL with
these big beards and [__] I thought they
were in their 40s yeah and I'm like
these this is a 22 year olds are
children yeah yeah so I do have the
thing
because there's days where it's like out
of sight out of mind I started getting
an appreciation for that like
it's something I didn't want to spend
time my daughter or talk to her on the
phone every day
but you had to make an effort to like do
just in the sense of like uh
you know just if you forget I would get
a thing at the end of the night if I was
on the road and I just realizing like oh
it's a three hour time difference and
she's definitely asleep now I didn't
call her today at all and I'm like
and I'd always have this I'm like this
is it this is the beginning of the
therapy like my dad doesn't pay
attention to me
and it's funny to put that pressure on
myself that she's like she's just you
know if you're a good father to your
kids
even if you [__] up and do things wrong
like they know you're going to of course
oh yeah you're uh a good father you know
I mean like if you're a president they
they don't
they don't have the pressure on you that
you have on you yet so I remember my
daughter I'd go okay Isabel when this
thing started to happen a little bit and
I'd be traveling a lot more
and I'm like I know Isabelle's supposed
to see this weekend but like I I gotta
do a gig now I'm gonna be going for like
a week and whatever but when I come back
like let's make sure we go to dinner and
like I want to do this and and she'd be
like okay and I promise I'll call you
every day when I'm gone and she's like a
teenager you know she's like oh all
right like what's the thing are you like
dying and I'm like no but just know that
I'm here and like you know I'd be so
worried about that
you know uh vocalize now so will you say
drifting off but I'm I was really
processing myself so
um you know my mom was your dad
basically my mom split and we were
raised by our dad and now I I'm I was
with you like I was scared of being a
parent at first because I was like what
if that's genetic you know what if
that's just in my [__] jeans to just
leave a [__] kid but I don't even
know I said I give that feeling too but
I think it's more like human is what it
is so my uh I think what I'm saying to
your point I'm it scared the [__] out of
me to be a shitty parent too which is
why I went hard the same way I'm like
I'll call you my daughter's eight she's
like all right I'll call you later yeah
I miss you and I love you by the way if
you forget to call the next morning we
wake up when you call and you're
apologizing she's like oh yeah what all
right yeah yeah
um
but again I see the thing where it's
about the effort and having the sympathy
for it is just like
he's so I'm gonna give all the thing
he's 20 when I when I'm three years old
he's 23 22 23.
he's put he's a kid like what really
just felt like got taken off his plate
was responsibility
and he's not even thinking long term of
what it's going to be such a kid you
know I mean he's like a kid so I do feel
the thing like
of course his life like he probably
liked his new wife and was enjoying
[__] her and but how old was your mom
when he left her same age right so it
was his 22 year old woman oh you has to
have all the responsibility and I'm oh
no I'm not saying it's not [__] up
with you I'm just saying I can
sympathize what I'm saying your mom was
able to handle that oh yeah he never
could have no no no for sure never could
have because of exactly the thing I get
the idea and I found myself falling into
it I don't think my daughter even Minds
saying it's like she's never a burden to
me ever in any situation at all but
there might be a night in my life where
I was like you know
even just some weird like you know it's
like let's do something [__] sexually
weird tonight or so you know and it's
like
um me and Mom are arguing like can I
come stay at your place and you're like
make up with each other you know what I
mean that's like now it's like if she
goes I have to and she's crying you're
coming over yeah the whole thing's
different I'm saying like there's nights
where you're like I don't want to be a
dad dude I want to do something weird or
[__] you know what I mean like yeah I
don't want to be there and so I I assume
and when
it's I think it's like almost like
working out but your dad was like I want
that every night of course yeah I'm
gonna go to Florida but it's almost like
when I've done Exercise at points I've
gotten a dick that addiction to it
nothing
I was amazing at it I'm just saying I
remember that feeling where it's like no
no I have to go
to the gym and if you don't do that for
a week it's you remember that thing
where it's like I'm not going to go I
got 15 minutes free in my day I'm not
going to the [__] gym for where other
time you'd be like I gotta do it
and I just think like you fought a habit
and I think his life just became easier
he's not right he's wrong he's actually
a shitty father uh when I was a kid for
that in many ways but I get it also you
know what I'm saying oh you're just like
yeah at 22 you decide to be like I don't
have to take care of this kid really
like oh then [__] it but then he went to
Florida and had two more kids
so he came back to like outside of
Philly after Florida
and I was my first stepmother Kathy and
she had kids she was great I actually
liked her a lot
and um
so he's seeing you how often now
weekly supposed to be every other week
I'd say the real estimate would probably
be like once a month maybe maybe but
he's within driving distance now local
45 an hour maybe somebody at Delaware at
one point like South Jersey and
everything we were in West Philly
what's funny is when we went moving to
South Jersey I'm like wow it's like we
really moved right to where he was sort
of but he was already gone
but uh he was with her for a while and
then
started uh
seeing I think a lady at work and his
companies was based out of Ohio
he was a good traveling he drove around
he drives
a truck and goes and tests it's such a
weird job it's an environmental job
weirdly but it's testing underground
diesel tanks for leaks
okay so he has to do some test he goes
and runs this weird probe test and
he goes and it's traveling a bunch and
headquarters was Ohio
and he met I think my current stepmother
there and then left my first stepmother
for her and just became an Ohio guy
overnight
and then I saw him once a year on like
the summer times maybe that was it was
an arbitrary he would take me but he
like lived as and he also I feel like I
was just in the way my stepmother didn't
dig me very much
um which again as I've got an older
sympathy for like I was probably an
annoying fat kid like I used to say her
mean things I'm like this lady was like
make me feel awkward like she would hide
the snacks in like a closet in her room
because I would eat too many of the
snacks and then I don't think you think
back I'm like I was killing myself just
shoveling snacks in my life yeah but
also because the guy she's married to
now [__] bailed on you and you're
probably eating feelings
no knows what I'm saying she was it's
all on us like I feel like we're that
generation that really is trying to
break these [__] kind of Cycles like
I don't want to be a shitty dad like
that guy it scares you yeah but then
also to have the balance to be like but
I [__] get it you were 23 years old
dude I don't blame you like they don't
even have that you know what I really
don't I don't I probably do I have like
resentment stuff towards my dad
ultimately but like
so it's funny when I tell these stories
like over the years of my dad and some
of the goofy [__] he's done
uh with me as a father I always come
back to him like so they go
and then one of those people come on the
road with me and I go so my dad's
running my dad anything in a two-hour
Drive he's at the show well now he's
there
she loves being Gary dude he loves being
Gary and he takes pictures with the fans
he fully grasped by the way that I'm
like they're kind of laughing at him but
like
no investment whatsoever but let me reap
all the rewards all up in there you know
it's funny there's such characters like
in my storytelling too that like when he
brought Diane my stepmother the one time
to pick with uh Pickwick and frolic
someone goes he goes oh we gotta have uh
Gary we gotta have uh big Gary in the
picture and he comes out oh is it the
mean stepmom like they're like they're
characters and my stepmom just like
she just pops into going so
um yeah so I do have sympathy for her
but again I was a child I was a kid and
like but then he has two boys with her
she's not very warm and then yeah and
then what it is is you just feel I think
it's like the classic
like well I'm just a reminder of like
his old life we got a family here
basically what she said one time which
was insane but I was like no not him
I was like no I started comedy so I was
probably 19 I just started and I was
like oh you know it won't impress my I
was still there I'm like you know don't
press this guy and get him to be like
stoked like I'm gonna
call a comedy club there and see if I
can do some guest spots on that uh
weekend and I did
it was uh so there's Lisa Lampanelli was
headlining I didn't know her at all
and uh I wanted to do guest spots and
she uh
while we were up there my dad goes oh he
goes he told me he's like bring some
nice clothes because uh
we're taking they're doing like pictures
like you were taking professional
pictures and I was like I don't even
want to do that but I'm like okay
so I bring them we go and it's my dad my
stepmom there too the kids were pretty
little at that point
it's like 20 some years ago and uh
and like you know her brother her
family's all from there so they're her
brothers and their families and her
sister and their found all the kids
there you go and my dad married in
to a woman so that's the okra family
there and uh they were like okay the
oakerson's now coming for the thing and
I'm considering my girlfriend I don't
even think this is lame anyway and I'm
like
I gotta go and I start going there and
she my stepmother goes like Oh
no I thought I meant like our family
like that I was like in front of my like
girlfriend and stuff like and I had to
do like the ah yeah no it's like I don't
even really want to take pictures anyway
I'm like yeah
the first time she saw me do comedy she
said uh yeah the first time she saw me
do comedy like where I was like
confident like I was doing well it
wasn't like I had an audience like a
personal audience yet but like I could
do well in the new in the clubs when I
went on and it was like a sold out
something in New York they came out they
came after my wedding
and I came into a sold out show like
state of New York or somebody had a good
set great set from what I remember and
she comes outside and she was like I
just don't understand why it's got to be
like so dirty it was like our first
words it's gonna be so dirty it's like
lady
I get it's not for you but like Katie
just acknowledge it like he went well it
went well yeah everyone else is kind of
like that's neat you know my mother came
to a show in Baltimore where I was
featuring for Segura back when he was
still doing clubs and she came out and
she's like you were okay he's really
funny and it's this ongoing thing now
that Segura is my mom's favorite [__]
comedian
laughs
that's what she said I was like Jesus
Christ I'm not even invited you just
came I have one of the funniest of that
is John you know John radninsky great
dude very funny his mom
look she's my biggest fan like when he
moved to New York State they would come
to the shows a bunch because he moved
out for SNL his mom just like and she is
a prim and pro she says I don't like
dirty stuff at all she goes but I just
something and she just loves my filthy
comedy it's so funny though and she's
such a sweet lady
um it's funny we turn somebody like that
but uh oh that's what I was saying with
my dad they'll know the story so much
and stuff like I've told people stuff
like you know that story and then people
you're with my dad they're just like
so wait I'm gonna meet this guy right at
the club I would see and I go no no
Charming is all I'm like you're gonna
love him I go he's a great hang he
shoots the [__] and my stepmom dips off
he'll like smoke cigarettes and talk
[__] still or smoke pot even so but
another thing I thought he gave me was
good was a responsibility with uh
drugs probably because my dad's a
pothead always not anymore but like all
through my time I remember as a kid and
I quote unquote catch him several times
you know walk in on him several times
and then when we have a long we moved to
Ohio and he'd pick me up to drive me
there for the summer for a couple weeks
he ain't doing that long of a car ride
without smoking one and for real yeah
and he would smoke a joy while he's
driving you yeah we were in a by the way
not only that somebody not knowing your
kid I'm a little fat kid and he shows up
to show off he always liked stuff like
this too he's like we get into like a
classic Stingray Corvette oh my God yeah
with my suitcase for the summer I mean
it's like and my dad was a bigger guy
too like smaller than me but like
bigger and like you know just like
sitting like this like squeezed up in a
stingray for you as well I have such a
visual of like
going down the road he's smoking a joint
out the window a joint and looking at me
and looking at me and giving me at like
I'm gonna I'll be fair and say 13 or 14.
it may have been a little younger but
he's giving me the uh you know when you
turn 18 I'd rather you do this than
drink because it was from the earth I
remember that's the first time I heard
like the from the earth thing and I'm
like I'm like all right I guess like it
just seems weird
uh he was over explaining it so much
that that's how I knew it was something
bad
yeah because I always just equated like
pot with being just like
something that like a idiot does yeah
because it was always like kind of his
thing that I I didn't know the
correlation but because of that I didn't
really smoke
until I was like 23 I did a few times at
that point and then when I was probably
about 27 or so it was when I became like
an everyday like pot smoker and
while I do say I really would have loved
to see the go back
it wouldn't be a good idea but I would
love to see the outcome of a smoking pot
in high school because I'm like man
maybe that's why it wasn't that awesome
I didn't say maybe taught in high school
that would have been really fun like
just go take I probably would have been
more interested in like a history thing
no what they did it
but instead I was just like I was just
looking out the window like can we leave
here I hate this
I had so many friends that would get
high and go to class and stuff or even
trip on acid they tell me later I'm like
yes we're on and I'm not doing any of
that [__] I'm drinking I'm drinking but
I'm not doing anything
when I go to school either because
they're going to smell it but these
[__] are high and on acid and
shrooms and [__] I'm like what so great
what no wonder you like this so I never
but I do believe because that I never
really found a problem with like any
drugs or even drinking because I just
I just didn't do it until then by the
time I did it and I was like oh this is
pretty fun I was at an eight also having
a kid young and getting into those
things after that was kind of like oh
yeah it's like I'll have a couple uh
shots and a beer if I'm not driving but
then most of the time it's like
you want to do a shot I'd say no to the
first one not because I'm like a goody
it was because like well I don't get the
point of doing one like now that I get
it like I do a few shots and get loose
but if I'm not gonna do that it's gross
and I have to drive like home at the end
of the night and take care of a baby
when I was little and then as she got
older and older so I just didn't do it
and then
by the time I had that freedom to kind
of do it it was like a responsible I
hope age although I'm getting charged
for smoking in my hotel room here are
you really weed or a cigarette weed I
would never do cigarette in the hotel
room for my own I don't smoke inside my
house or anything that's great they're
really charging you yeah yeah they the
worst thing is Bert and then put us up
so Bert's tour manager who I know thank
God called me today and said they're
gonna charge the two I was like oh yeah
it happens once in a while ago I'll pay
it how much is it 250. that's not bad
I uh
tomorrow morning I leave and I got the
call right before I came here and it was
like yeah and I was like yeah uh I said
yeah it happens sometimes yeah I'll pay
it and then she goes uh and they just
just say that like if they smell it
happen again like they're gonna ask you
to leave the hotel and I'm like
so right on the edge
because you know what I mean it's like
yeah if I do at midnight
is it gonna be a problem like I think
this happens I smoked today before I
left for the first thing so there's just
housekeeping still there I'm like
to it there you go I definitely want to
be kicked out of the hotel at two
o'clock in the morning but
we'll see all right so now let's talk
about you getting married you're married
first before you have a baby no no
classic white trash she was the she was
a flower girl dude what was she for
those flowers yeah yeah she was five or
six when we got married I remember when
my daughter's mother was like we were
talking about like a wedding and stuff
and I was like well if we do that then
the kids won't be in the wedding she's
like your kids aren't supposed to be in
your wedding I was like oh yeah there's
that they're not they're not oh yeah
we're going traditional all right we're
not traditional classic yeah we never
even got them potluck dinner now you
guys don't do that I've been to family
weddings where like somebody in the
family did the cooking and like it's
those tin foil trays with the candy
flower crock pot over there
pretty Philly too it's like yeah loose
roast beef sandwiches there's always a
dry ass ziti
yeah a dry ziti meatballs I've seen
their better day
[Laughter]
um so when okay so you guys were
together for how long before you got
married
um my daughter was probably seven years
okay I want to say and like yeah seven
or eight years and it was
I was doing so much
like others like just Road stuff and I
think I got caught in something pretty
bad I don't think I did I thought it was
before that really bad
thought maybe we might break up then but
even I didn't want to again because it
kind of came down to one I love my
ex-wife I still she's great you know I
mean she's a there's nothing with her it
was all like me in this I'm not even
absolving her a blame of anything in the
relationship going apart but I'm saying
for me for sure I was never like
All In
without doing like some grimy [__] to
some degree
but uh after I got caught with that we
decided to stay together
and I was just doing things kind of like
maybe here and there I was trying to be
a little better like you know not having
a side like life or girlfriend and just
like [__] on the road a little bit not
make it a big deal
and uh and I was feeling so good about
like maintaining that for a bit that I
was like
yeah we should we should make this kid
have a family you know I mean Isabella
should have like her family be a family
although you want to get and she was so
stoked that she would yes immediately
and but I mean it was asked like while I
was like smoking out like my sliding
glass doors or my thing
she was planning by an hour later yeah I
swear to you I was like hey hey Carla
are you want to say [__] get married
what do you think
a throw party Famous Last Words
um and then yeah so we did it was a
great man such a fun memory the wedding
was [__] great but yeah and then we
uh
and you're together for about four years
before you split you said she was your
daughter was around 12. well we're still
currently not divorced that's still an
ongoing process still because that is
our only
kind of headbutt at all is like it's not
even a head butt like
she just she has a another child who's
great
uh with somebody else afterwards and
she's not with him anymore
she had a boyfriend for a while now I
don't think it's like a romantic thing
but
when I whenever it's like hey you gotta
like sign this so you have to respond to
this email like it's you know I might
want to buy a house one day like I don't
want it to be half yours like yeah it's
weird
we've been broken up for
[__] 11 year 10 years
and uh
so you know but she's like whenever it's
like so you gotta do this that's when
it's contentious
so that's what is her reason for if
you're can even talk about it what's her
reason for wanting to stay married
if I could tell you I I I don't think
it's the chiefly even cares about
staying married I don't think she wants
to get divorced I see does that make
sense I don't think she wants to be a
divorce it's like uh I think she views
it as like a failure maybe in some way
or something but like you know I'm
always like how about your other
daughter that wouldn't exist if I didn't
do all these wonderfully Terrible Things
yeah you don't get that opportunity yeah
if I didn't cheat on you this Angel
wouldn't exist so think about that next
time you start pointing your fingers so
when you
what's your first night like alone with
your daughter she's 12 and she's coming
to your place
what's that like that took a minute that
took a minute too that was again you
told me those like Father things you
like and somebody don't even realize you
do them it's like I'm glad my daughter
feels comfortable to talk to me
about it but like
it was like her birthday a couple years
ago we were out her mom got a little
zipped and started taking some like
quiet shots at me
she wanted her to go to college my
daughter and I have much more of like oh
I'm like I'll pay for you to go to
college if you want to go a couple what
do you want to go to college for I'm
like she doesn't know so I'm like why
would you just arbitrarily go to college
anymore I'm like don't do whatever you
want to do he's a college graduate I
completely agree yeah I've had that
conversation with my daughter look if
you want to go if you're going to do
nursing or something it's a prerequisite
for the career yes but if it's not
fairly go and she's also and again it's
the difference too like her mother is an
academic
uh for sure you know I mean but she's uh
and I'm not an academic I'm much more of
a creative and my daughter just Falls
more on that side of the fish she's a
great artist you know what I mean but
like
she doesn't really see what the career
would be in that necessarily and she
doesn't really know what she wants to do
so she's gonna go to esthetician school
now I'm like fantastic that's tangible
you'll make money in that in a little
bit you know like instead of just taking
like
psych 101 because you have no idea what
you're taking
and uh but she was taking like these
kind of uh little pot shots at me
and it did come up the story came up and
I was like you know when you left
like you told Isabella
that when she asked why you were taking
the TV
you said that you were house sitting for
a friend for a little bit and he didn't
have a TV
so and I was like
I do sort of remember when they said it
but I blocked it I was probably wrong
where I just sort of forgot because
there's so many things happened such a
depressing and sad time even though it
it's what I wanted ultimately it was so
depressing and sad and I felt terrible
and um and yeah my daughter was like
yeah yeah he did and I was like yeah but
like
and then I corrected that at some point
and it was like no that was like never
but you just never lived back in the
house again and I was like damn so
anytime I bring up I go yeah I did that
100 wrong that's not even it was the
pussiest way to handle it like my
daughter's heard me say that so like I
think she appreciates that you know what
I mean yeah especially come on I've
apologized to her for things that I
think are like you know I mean and I'd
always hear anything that she was like
upset with and I was like yeah you
deserve all that [__] you don't get born
to your parents split up it's nothing so
then I I think of things like that and
then I think of like when when we split
my daughter was one she was like no I'm
not doing this so all my daughter has
known is back and forth 50 50. so I
can't decide if that's better to know it
like that the whole time like I remember
my daughter said to me one time she was
like three or four and she said um
something about living together like a
real family and I said listen to me we
are a real family sure I said these
people your neighbors that live next
door to each other who live together
these people above you or in these
neighborhoods around you just because
they live in the same under the same
roof does not mean they're a good family
doesn't mean they're a healthy family
doesn't mean they have all the [__] that
you really want I'm telling you don't
ever say that again and she got that
pretty quick no it's good too no I feel
the same way
with her mom too I'm like this is your
family we're your family you know when
you get married one day me and your
mother are going to be you know and not
at each other's throats that's not the
way anybody wants to be no if you are
trying to improve your health hydration
is a great place to start and liquid IV
is dehydration brand that fuels your
well-being their hydration multiplier is
the one product you're missing in your
daily routine in just one stick you get
five essential vitamins and two times
faster hydration than water Alone look
you know how much we love liquid IV here
they keep coming back because you guys
love them too and I'm telling you we
keep them here at the studio and give
them out I get bags of this stuff and I
give them to people my producer Kirsten
her husband use it I take it I start
every day like that I always put it in a
bottle of water to take to the gym and
now they've got energy multipliers
they've got ones to help you sleep
there's a one for immunity there's even
a kombucha one now so there's something
for everybody I like the um the orange
Citrus one that's got that vitamin C
kick y'all you know what I'm saying with
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks it's made with
premium ingredients non-GMO and it's
free from gluten dairy and soy so grab
your liquid I've heavy and bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get
twenty percent off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use my code honeydew at
checkout that's 20 off of anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com there's no quick fix for
anxiety and depression it's not finding
a new therapist or starting an exercise
routine it's not more in regular
meditation or a better diet I know
everybody out there has got the solution
for your problems you know have you
tried yeah yup tried all of it all right
and sometimes you just need something to
unlock your brain a new way of thinking
about and seeing the world and maybe
that thing has guided ketamine therapy
from mind Bloom listen I did this okay I
did six sessions of it for anxiety and
I'm telling you it absolutely makes a
difference I thought differently I just
spent the month in the hospital and
there were days I felt cool as a
cucumber even though I was going through
the craziest stuff I've ever gone
through in my life so I know that it
worked and I know that it helped there's
a new new tool to improve your mental
health at home ketamine therapy mind
Bloom is the leader in at home ketamine
therapy having safely helped thousands
of people overcome their anxiety and
depression and unlike traditional talk
therapy ketamine Works quickly and
doesn't have the unpleasant side effects
of traditional antidepressants in a
study of over 1 200 mind Bloom clients
89 percent reported improvements in
their anxiety and depression after only
two sessions right now mind Bloom is
offering my listeners a hundred dollars
off your first six session program when
you sign up at mindbloom.com Honeydew
and you use the promo code honeydew take
the first step and break free from your
anxiety and depression with mind Bloom
mindbloom.com honeydew and use promo
code honeydew nah let's get back to the
do
um but did it take you getting some used
to
um to not only I mean to be a single dad
also is like you got this child that
comes over all the time interesting
thing well she wasn't over all the time
that's kind of interesting thing it
would be like more she eventually did
start coming and staying over
uh sometimes I think her mom was a
little uncomfortable I mean you know
she's also essentially
taking her to someone's house
my ex-wife to her credit there's TV
there though yeah
my my ex-wife my ex-wife to her credit
really
did for the longest time like
the best she could and really good at
like
if I mean my girlfriend essentially is
like I didn't leave her for her
he was just meeting my girlfriend was
the thing that I was like oh that's like
I'm just more in line
with what I want to do in life and some
things with uh her do you know what I
mean so it's like uh
it's not an anger
at the other one trying to think of
where my head is at such a bad pothead
with remembering what I was talking
about as I tangent off well I was asking
you if it took you some time to get used
to like co-parenting and being cool with
her and then also when your daughter
started coming over what I did more in
the beginning which was good so
you know it's difficult uh as well it's
hot like there is something to it I tell
my daughter in like a joking fashion but
she also knows it's like an actual thing
but I don't regret a second of it I
never wanted her to think that but I'm
like oh having her so young
certainly slowed my career down how
young were you when she was born 24.
yeah it's young and I just turned 24 too
it was a month in the 24. it's our two
months she's uh and yeah I was like when
everyone I knew was like
I want to go hit La for a couple weeks
and couch Surf and whatever I was like
no I gotta go do black circuit shows and
make money like or like you know I mean
so I really couldn't
uh so it did for sure
but so when I left
and you know my ex it was it was not
contentious right away but like she was
mad with me for sure understandably so
we still communicated and everything but
she was not super psyched but what I was
able to do
was it did free me up and I was
wondering if it was maybe mentally my
girlfriend said this before and she it
may be right like also there's a thing
that maybe I didn't push to find
and the next level of like success or
anything because like the fear of like
how much am I going to bury myself into
something I'm not sure if it's what I
want to be in the rest of my life so I'm
like are we gonna buy a house now we
have assets we're going to buy that you
know I mean I was worried about that
and started thinking about that and I'm
also like now I'm stunting her life too
from finding those things so I kind of
uh split but
the um
co-parenting was really and again much
credit to my ex she
really took the reins of like
it was rare that I was picking her up
from
practices she lived in Long Island too I
was I moved to Manhattan
and for the first couple years until I
started making some dough I didn't have
a car so I was like I have to take the
thing to the subway to the Long Island
Railroad in an hour and a half out I did
it a lot
but I didn't see it and when I I kind of
put my nose to the grindstone more of
work and really
that sometimes becomes a point of
attention too almost all of my
finally like success as far as like
feeling financially like I'm not
underwater and I'm doing all right
happened after I left which I know
creates a resentment for sure but
because of that the co-parenting to
answer the long way around to get to the
answer of that is um I wasn't as present
as I would have been living there and
not even like uh uh you know she came
over every other weekend thing but I was
able to finally like
yeah put her in that private school for
sure you want to bring out a prize go
put in that private school oh how much
does that like girls lacrosse cost three
thousand dollars to join I'm like all
right well here's and I'm doing all of
so I'm saying I took care of them and
stuff I made sure they had a car that
was paid for and they didn't have to
worry about that so I was I felt for
like one of the first times you know we
always got by together but I was like I
was able to provide almost for the first
time and it's like to send them on
vacations with the with the my
daughter's sister and stuff to go see
and like uh
and that's been good I think she's like
a I don't think she appreciates it
enough but that's probably what most
students would say it's the best did you
ever see
did you ever see the uh there's a great
cutaway in family an episode of Family
Guy if you're a fan and it's Stewie uh
it says like oh now we got to go to the
park and look at all of the uh divorced
dads uh playing for their hour with
their kids or something as a guy pushing
a little girl like way too like hard
like almost aggressively on a swing and
he goes hey he goes how's uh he goes
those are really cute shoes you got do
they cost twenty five hundred dollars a
month because that's what I'm giving
your mother and she's like it's just a
shotgun thing
about child support too is like if your
kids heard how you talked about it and
you go it's like you go is that too much
money to spend on your kid you go it's
not don't look at it that way what it is
it's probably less or comparable to what
I spend on you anyway it's just never
laid out like that you know I mean it's
like 2500 it's probably not that much of
a thing but you're like you don't really
see it like here's this bulk but then
you realize that's you know she's eating
all month and all that kind of [__]
medical bills I never had like a with a
quarter of Child Support or anything I
just always I mean I kept the receipts
but
in case that ever but I mean but now
your child's an adult and now she's 20
and that's funny now she's out of the
house and like you know and what's your
relationship like now everybody shows oh
yeah yeah she loves you yeah yeah we got
to keep her uh Louis J Gomez he's like
him and Dave my partners asked literally
because they're having a hard time and I
get it they're not wrong
they just noticed that she was a baby
like a literal baby so they're having a
hard time being them they're gross and
whatever stories we're telling selves
when she's there yeah there's definitely
been things she was there for I was like
I wish she wasn't there for that but for
the most part
she's 20. I just I do I see her as 20.
it's not like I still see her as a kid
if it makes sense yeah but I also know
her and I trust her in a way where it's
just like
I don't know like was it the last time
she was there though they were like they
pulled me outside they're like dude I go
all right I'll tell her to take a break
from coming she just loves like she
likes it she brings her friends and they
think it's great
and uh
like I'm having a hard time and that
show circumstantially
um this guy named Byron who was
auditioning to be an intern sucked his
own dick on stage
he got the job he did I remember looking
over
I remember looking over my dog
and I'm like well Point made guys I
won't bring her anymore
it's a dollar yeah I'll ask you to maybe
steer clear a little bit no she always
wants to come to the festival we do and
oh [__] I I said I really really love
it's funny like the the years that I
wasn't like every day with her
again it was such a switch because we
did that's
she was my but I was young too so like
when she got like eight years old nine
and ten it was like I can go get like
Lego Indiana Jones games and stuff like
that and just we should go from school
and like I'd help her rush through her
homework so we can like play like she
was my butt it was great I love that
that we had that
and being with her mother longer than I
was for that is more than worth that
more more than worth that and and then
to kind of skip to now it's like I think
it's so cool she'll call me when I think
she's like hey my roommate's out on a
date like I'm like what are you doing
you want to like watch TV or something
or you know want to watch a movie and
she's close to you like she'll come over
um well she's in Brooklyn I'm in
Manhattan and she's kind of out in
Brooklyn so it's a crazy train ride but
she knows she knows like how much I want
her to love me
so I was like you know I should
definitely give like a it's just
probably gonna take me like two hours on
the train you're like I'll get you a
[__] Uber you [__] because she
knows but I mean the fact that she like
I love that she wants to hang out yeah
we go to several Sixers games a year we
like go to concerts she comes to
concerts with us like yeah I can't wait
for that it was a great time she knows I
smoke weed I got caught by her which was
a funny one how old was she and I called
her it was funny I rectified away
because I said we were talking earlier
about this stuff of my dad
funny how it hit she was 17.
she's living with her mom
and I was texting with everyone like
just bullshitting and my friend
Wayne I was going to his house but I was
running late so this isn't even true uh
when I'm texting him but I just wanted
to make an excuse
for running late I go hey I'm just gonna
roll a few more uh joints and go to the
and stop by the deli you want anything
from the deli and then I don't
like look at it and then I get the you
know the vibration comes I look and it's
my daughter text me and she goes get me
a sandwich dog
and I wrote back
huh I I clearly see that I wrote about
Holly we're having a conversation like
in person I went huh and then I felt so
stupid for that more than even the [__]
up for texting and treating her so
stupid is to be like what I didn't even
send that that must be a mistake I just
called her right away and I was like all
right your dad smoked spot let's talk
and it was who was cool about that those
I was also able to tell her I go and
just you know like my dad I told her the
whole thing I just told you and I was
like and I really didn't start smoking
with any regularity I was like 27 years
old I tell I just had this conversation
with my daughter because unfortunately a
friend of ours his daughter got a hot
shot in Baltimore and she died of
Fentanyl and
um he came to visit us and you know he
was crying I was crying I was like how
are you doing and he's like you know
we're doing good and so then she asked
me and we we flew into Philly and drove
down the Ocean City that's where we went
Maryland and on the ride back she's like
why was he crying and what was going on
I was like all right you know what it
was that same long ride I was like this
is what's going on so I explained to her
about Fentanyl and I'm like you're in
elementary school I know you have
friends who
um have older siblings like if you see
any pills don't take any of that and
then I was like I smoke marijuana and I
explained to her that marijuana is
medicine even with what I just went
through these doctors are telling me
it's okay to smoke and if I I prefer
that to Xanax then go ahead and I have
them talking about that recorded so that
she can hear real doctors say hey this
thing is can be used as medicine yeah
you don't like demonize it I told her I
was like you're getting a different
education and probably every kid in your
elementary school is getting about
marijuana right now oh yeah she's like
how come this and that I was like well
there's a difference between medicinal
and recreational and some people just
they don't want to get up make Studios
and podcasts they just want to lay on
the [__] couch and watch a sports
center yeah I was like yeah charged 250
in a stupid Hotel
no it's funny my daughter and people say
I'm naive
I don't think I am I I I'm certain
there's elements of my daughter that I'm
unaware of
uh she's told me she would not involve
me in anything with guys she's talking
to or dating or God forbid hooking up
with so she doesn't bring any boyfriends
to your shows or anything like that
never I've never met a boyfriend I
wouldn't even be if you asked me if she
was dated it ever went on a date with a
guy I go I've seen no evidence of that
but I'm sure she has yeah but she's kept
that clean and friends of mine who she's
close with also she like does some like
assistant work for once in a while
my friend Michelle like she could
confides and Michelle and Michelle
doesn't like tell me anything but she's
like of course she dates and there's
guys she's interested in but she told me
she's like no I will not bring a guy
around you until I want to like be
serious with him and I was like why I
can't make sure because you're gonna
like terrify them right away and she
doesn't mean like
because she knows I'm not like uh my
baby girl better be home like I'm not
that person she's just like you're gonna
like make fun of his pants until he like
doesn't want to be around me anymore and
I'm like oh that might happen and you
and your friends are gonna like run
you're gonna take it you're gonna put a
picture of him up on your podcast and
everything and I'm like yeah these are
all you got me that is a thing so I'm
like but she'll
go and like she's told me she smoked pot
before I believe she doesn't drink I'm
not saying she doesn't at all but I
think she doesn't really much because
I've given her like you know like like a
martini I was like oh that's alcohol you
know like we went to the steakhouse a
couple weeks ago and I was like and she
was like is it and she's like did it I
could see it like the real because it's
me all right same I'm not a big I hate
the taste of alcohol and so I think she
doesn't use it a lot I think she
probably smokes weed a little bit she
doesn't smoke cigarettes she probably
has Vaped a bunch and uh but I've even
answer about the drug she's told me
about drugs she's been around and stuff
like that and I'm like you've never even
tried it at all and like I think I
believe that she believes if she said I
tried cocaine once that I will talk with
her about it I'm like here's why you
should not do that which I've already
done especially today no defense it's
not even safe but I believe her when she
says she goes no now she goes I think
she goes my friends really think like if
you die from drugs like how lame
that well your time on Earth is like so
useless you died from drugs that's a
great [__] attitude I believe her if
it makes sense at the same time also
that she might try Molly one do you know
what I'm saying I don't I'm not
disconnected I don't think because also
I'll say what are you doing tonight and
she'll be like oh this underground party
they're doing on the Bronx it's like
under this bridge and it's like DJs and
everything and then what so what time uh
they go to the cops come and then
everyone kind of like
you know they break it up I'm like are
they arresting people to go no they just
like come and make everyone kind of
break down and leave
and I'm like what time you get into this
kind of whenever that happens and I mean
if that's
the latest like four in the morning
where she was at and I say well if
you're doing that like please let me
know if you need an Uber first you know
if you but do not get on the subway and
let me know when you're home safe like
she'll call me and like I could tell by
her voice she's not like [__] whacked
out or anything you know I mean like
it's like hey we're home so and so threw
up you know whatever and we're back now
like I can't answer more than that at
that age hell years old yeah 20 no [__]
no
you know so I'd be but I can't I'm
almost excited because and you'll see
this I think without excited to see what
happens your daughter's oh she's only
eight she's eight years old so it's
interesting to see the things that
happen
that seem like you're like when your dad
exactly them having sex then whatever
piercings tattoo you're like oh I'm
gonna somehow like
it's just is what it you know I mean my
daughter's got like
four tattoos not big but like three of
them are horrible
like shitty artwork somewhere I told her
I go Isabella uh tell me when you when
you really want to get another tattoo
and let's get you like a really good
idea if you can do it and get you an
actual artist because I go it's insane
there's things you have to live with
forever now on this
on your dumb skin but like uh but even
the first thing she had a tattoo like
you get the initial you're like okay
here it is that moment and then
same thing without her going to a uh you
know three years ago it's in your mind
you like she had like a uh not even a
curfew she was to really go out and do
like friends like late night stuff it
wasn't her thing now she did an
overnight Rave thing that's happening
and so when it's happening you're just
like the reason it's okay when she when
I find out she had sex or you know if
she has now I don't know and if if
whenever I find out that she did
whatever it was or she has a boyfriend
I'm not sure
something about is that even as drastic
as it all seems
if you know them
is what makes it not that so much she
has tattoos now I'm like tattoos but I'm
like it still [__] Isabella it's
really dumb tattoo on her behind her ear
now you know I mean like [__] and the
fact that I can and also a relationship
where I can go it's like stop getting
shitty tattoos you [__] idiot you
know what I mean yeah and she's like my
look so I I think that's like
can you can't really that's what I'm
saying that sounds [__] amazing you
kind of get like you just get over
because you're like yeah it's a human
thing right and she's a person her own
person and she's eventually gonna [__] a
guy she's eventually gonna have a
relationship she might she might [__] a
guy that she meets one night and that
guy's kind of shitty too or never talks
to her again and she [__] whatever it
is like what it is like at the end of
the day they're you don't love her
because of the sum of her mistakes you
know it's very well said
do you see we got deep this is the sum
of her mistakes
we'll be right back
after these messages
all right I asked you also we talked
before we were recording about not just
getting deep but also if you had any
embarrassing stories people done you you
put up two yeah and I would love to
[__] go out on those
um you guys he got seen Kevin Hart and
Sixers audience
yeah the Sixers audience is a pretty
funny one well
actually I'll go sequentially I'll tell
the Kevin Hart when it's fun in
Sacramento
he um
Kev is performing at these couple years
ago and Kevin Hart for the background
started the guy me and him started
together
me him and Kurt Metzger Kev
but two years we drove from Philly to
New York every day you know five six
days a week uh with Keith Robinson and
we were just buddies you know we just
hit it off me and Kev Kev kinda
went to LA
uh sort of quick and he went to Montreal
pretty quick and then he got stuff in
small parts things he was moving and
shaking
uh and then
I just kind of had the slow steps like
going so it where our worlds come back
and Collide several years after not
seeing each other
he's headlining the hell he's performing
and headlining at the Arco Arena which
is where the Sacramento Kings play I'm
doing
85 shows in six days at the punchline
yeah and I get a hold of Kev for advice
for I don't remember which but I one of
us knew the other one was in town
somehow probably let's assume it was me
reaching out but he was like yo come
hang at the hotel for a little bit
and I was like all right
and I get a cab and I take the cab
25 minute drive or so to and the guy's
asking me the cab driver's like why are
you going if you don't let me asking
what are you going are you changing
hotels see I didn't see that luggage or
anything I go oh no and it's a cab
driver so you go oh you'll probably
think this is pretty cool I go uh Kevin
Hart I'm a comedian I'm in town doing
the punch line blah blah blah Kevin Hart
is a old friend of mine he's in town
doing the arena and he's like oh yeah I
know and I was like so I'm gonna go uh
visit him say hi catch up he's like oh
that's so cool and then he starts asking
a ton of questions about me
doing a
whatchamacles about me doing the shows
The Improv and I'm a comedian that's so
cool and that's it's being super
complimentary sort of and then after
some lull he goes
is it possible to get tickets at all
and I was like yeah sure I got a bunch
of shows just gotta let me know which
show and whatever he goes a bunch of
shows at the Arco Arena I was like oh
you went from a Kev show
I was like no no dude I don't know I
don't think I can get you tickets for it
I'm sorry and he's like oh man all right
I had to ask you know whatever and I'm
like
and it was quiet and awkward and when I
get out of the cab he goes
uh here's a card
because it's hard to get a cab out here
just like before Uber was everywhere
it's hard to get a cab out here so uh
take this call me give me five minutes
and I'll pick you up take you back
okay and it was awkward but I'm like who
cares drive me home I go Kev says meet
me in the hotel gym
the hotel gym I've never seen this
besides this hotel
the entrance Ford is outside it's like
through the hotel it's like the gym for
the hotel but yeah go outside
when we leave well first I stand there
because I'm not in workout clothes I
stand about he finishes up his workout
uh and you know lamenting his successes
I'm asking him In fairness but I'm just
like yeah what was it man he's like
specials and uh and you know Shaquille
o'neals
and then we uh wheelie we leave uh the
gym and it's
say about 30 yards from Jim door to the
front of the hotel
30 yards
shuts the city off I mean like car stop
people come out of buildings people yell
outside of windows they can't they're so
blown away and so psyched
Kevin Hart's taking this little walk
from his gym clothes in a towel just
going to the front
uh they also annoyingly in my mind I'm
going well they definitely got
insecurity also which sucks
and we go in the hotel go up to his room
and you know it's everything you think
is like a bunch of roots basically an
apartment top of this beautiful hotel
and you want uh you want a lobster we
got lobsters
it's a lot and I'm saying I'm also I'm
doing these seven and five I go that
weekend going like
headlining finally and then you get you
know it gets smacked in the face with it
again because I'm like again it's a
headline weekend it's all those shows
for like you know minimum guarantees and
stuff yeah you know this isn't like
money like you're yeah when you come
home from those gigs after buying food
all weekend and stuff you're coming home
with like hundreds of dollars that's
right
um
and and I'm watching his life just like
hitting me where I'm just like you
really feel like a failure and
I'm trying to
like find some oh and he's also showing
me his
guy's a crew there of like film crew
showing him the new intro for his
special it's like there's pyro and he's
being shot out of the floor and I'm like
you know in front of us sold out Arena
somewhere and I'm like
I'm just trying to look around for some
semblance of like not his part because
kev's Kev personality if I saw him
tomorrow I hope I see him at the Super
Bowl would be great
um
but he's just like uh
I I you know I go I'm trying to find
some semblance of like
connection man what's like something
that's we can relate to anymore still
and his boys are all playing Xbox 360.
NBA and I go up
still bringing the 360 on the road
though some things don't change right so
maybe the first words I said in 15
minutes because I'm just scanning for
something I go
some things never change right still
bringing the Xbox 360 I go me too Diego
mine's like hooked up in my room right
now
I got a game on pause actually and he
goes oh no no he's just saying a matter
of fact he's not like rubbing into my
face but you know when you're in that
zone
he's like uh oh yeah he goes uh he goes
no no we just when we land we have the
runner go grab one and then we just
leave it for the housekeeping to have
and I was just like I have to leave like
right I was like I gotta go I gotta get
ready for my show it's like 2 p.m
donating 360s every season Christ so I
so I go sorry
sorry I go um I have to leave I just
make some excuse I can get out of here
all right call the guy he comes pick me
up and he gets in the car and he goes
hey man he's like how was he's like he's
like probing a bit and I'm like it was
fine man like I know he's like was it
all what's he like and I'm like no I
know him I'm like it's like a old buddy
so I was like it's yeah he was great it
was good to see it was good to catch up
just trying to get out of the
conversation
and the guy goes by the way man I'm like
I feel really
like stupid for what I asked before he
goes if that uh
if that offer's still a table I'd love
to come see one of your shows if that's
okay and I was like uh yeah but you know
I'm almost disregarding of him but I'm
just like sure you know y'all get him
I'm like yeah man that's fine I'll I'll
get you tickets and he goes on about a
five minute thing about like oh man it's
gonna be so cool the punchline I'm gonna
bring my girl and be like yo I know the
comedian like would you be able to say
hi afterwards he's like
selling a knight of like this thing and
I'm like yeah dude totally it'll be
great
and then we sit quietly for like 25
minutes and I'm the whole 25 minutes I'm
just in my head going like
maybe I should have went to college like
I don't know I [__] doubt and
everything yeah I'm like I'm like
there's like such a gap between our
success
do you know I mean I'm just like I'm
like I'm like at this point I'm probably
in my 30s you know already I'm like like
maybe not deep 30s but like early to mid
to early mid 30s and I'm like I'm not
like anywhere like near okay like
financially at all
and I'm like it's just weighing on me
and then as I'm getting out of the he
pulls up in front of the hotel my stupid
shitty hotel
and I start to step out of the car and
he's like not saying anything and I go
uh manager you want to give me like uh
your info or take my you know I'm giving
my number you want my number for the
thing this guy looks
he means back and he goes dude I'll be
honest with you I'm probably not gonna
come
I had to go inside and call my mom to
not hang myself from a ceiling fan in
that hotel
one last kick in the nuts yeah for real
dude you're all ready do the oversell
and the thing goes oh man is it cool we
have a drink with you after we buy you a
shot afterwards like yeah man whatever
I'll say hi to you and your chick yeah
dude honestly he just didn't want the
ride home to be awkward so he got me all
gooseed up and then he's like yeah dude
I actually don't give a [__] bye
genius
it is pretty impressive and where
that'll flow into the other thing I
think you'll like yeah I think you'll
like where it flows into it is like so
it's always my
and Kev is you know unfortunately for me
I mean fortunately for me a friend and a
great dude but unfortunately you know
that's your gauge the person you're like
next to when you start what are they
doing
and also Metzger too when we went into
the mainstream comedy World more
whatever you want to call it you know
the out of the black circuit Kurt
because he was such a great joke writer
and so good at that already I now have
to adjust my hip-hoppy
like pandering comedy and kurts like
this so Kurt's giving us half hour
special before me and also so now I feel
like kurd's zipping me do you know I
mean you think last man out
and I've always just kind of carried
that stupid and particular things and
you'll appreciate this for sure as a
sports fan I know you are
I'm sorry you know I got a bat yeah yeah
you do it yeah you're the guy oh I heard
about a guy getting a bat
um
I I um
I watch Kev
uh on all these things one and I'll yell
from the rooftops and Kevin Hart I
genuinely love you and I root for you
every day he's not an Eagles fan
it's very easy to play Madden with Kevin
he's a Giants fan
now that may have just changed over the
years but if it did change in over the
years then you're a chick because then
that means a boyfriend made you a fan of
his team
let's see what it probably is He's a
Philly son you know I mean he's so known
that he kind of like I'm sure he became
an Eagles fan when they gave him
probably the key to the city
and I'm a huge Sixers fan too and like
just ever there's I mean after that uh
Niners Eagles game the my daughter loves
by the way she loves sending me a good
picture
of Kev killing it because she's like
don't you know him show he's like don't
you know yeah and it was like Joel
embiid with Kev celebrating with the
Eagles after the win and you're like God
damn it
and I
when I started making any kind of money
one of my first favorite things to do is
I'm you know I can't it's like when I
was a kid where I can go to
15 16 Sixers games a year
um like but if I go to a couple now so
when I go to the games I'm like I'll
drop a couple bucks so we can like no I
wanna I know the row I'm like I want to
sit seventh row and
um you know behind the this bench so we
can see the offense in the second hand I
just know we're gonna pay and they're
expensive and they vary of price but
they're always expensive
and through radio gigs because the
in-house announcer for the Sixers
is the uh
is a friend of mine because he I've done
his radio show a bunch and he's great
and when I started making a couple bucks
I remember saying uh I was like I want
to get a season ticket I'm gonna get 10
game
thing I'll give a couple away and I just
want but I want to see I want those
seats that I sit in were like comparable
and I go and like no it can really it's
always things like you have to fill out
a form and join like the Sixers Club
whatever and then you have to go on a
waiting list and all this stuff and I go
no man come on I'm like in entertainment
enough enough that I go I don't want
this for free
you told me the face value price for
these season tickets I'll pay but I just
want to get I don't want to go through
those rig and roll
I'm always gonna run around run around
people so they can do something for me
they can't
Matt cord is the name of the United
States so sweet sweet guy I see
something to him at one point I'm like
man I want to get something good
but it's again say I gotta join it to
corporate whatever and he goes
he's like I'm gonna tell them corporate
accounts that I'm gonna have a guy call
you and get to sorted out for you
I could tell when that guy called me
Matt core it's a sweet Testament hips
well I've never said a word about this
I've just acted like it never happened
because Matt definitely presented to
this guy
like this he goes uh hey
call this guy right here he goes
big jokerson he goes let's get some
season tickets
and I know it's like that where he's
going like
pretty cool right big this guy's
definitely like I have no idea who that
is so he calls me goes yeah Matt said uh
you were looking to get season tickets I
was like yeah man I really would like to
be like in this area and like yeah it
would mean the world to me I'm a
goosebumpy excited for this and he goes
so he goes you just gotta go online and
fill out like the Sixers Club he just
told me this process again I don't know
what you already did and then you go on
that waiting list and it's whatever and
I'm like oh that's so
I never asked Matt again if he doesn't
ask me about it he assumes probably that
when he sees me at my season pass season
tickets
so now I start going when I do go to
these games and sit good seats
I Loom at the floor seats
on the side of the benches because for
some reason that's the one I just know
him now the old man
who gets in problems every year by going
on the court uh he says the Sixth Man on
his thing he owns all the dormitories at
University of Pennsylvania that's why
he's there and he's a lunatic who thinks
he's part of the team
but he pays for it so they put him there
on the other side of the scores table
and like Shyamalan and whoever he brings
and a couple down
uh as a a lawyer named Tom Klein I found
this guy's commercials on TV because I'm
like who why does this guy look this is
interested I love it disinterested and
at 100 of the Sixers games
he must work in the buildings I don't
know it's crazy and his and his and his
girlfriend or wife
uh who is never not just like
feet on the floor of the Court never not
on her phone giving a [__]
he doesn't seem to be appreciate I don't
know what I want him to do but he's just
like so used to it by now he doesn't
think it's that big a deal Shyamalan I
get of course but you're also just like
why am I not sitting next to Sean and I
go and I have this envy and every game I
go to I just have someone where I'm like
especially if they lose you're like I'm
in a [__] hole like all this money
and gotta drive back to New York said
now he's [__] they don't care they
don't give a [__] when we were down by
10 with like two minutes left they left
happily like ah we're gonna have B
traffic
foreign
so one game
I go to with Christine my girlfriend and
we're sitting behind the Sixers bench
seven rows
I know they though row six I think
five or six that's why I always do seven
one of those two is the first seat that
rises oh okay I've paid big money for
the third or fourth row on the floor
if you're not first on the floor you
can't see everyone's level so oh is that
right oh they're all flat right there oh
that is the same thing we charge people
money for yeah
because if you're watching at
you know you're behind the one of the
benches so you're basically like
three-quarter Court
like when you have to turn like if
there's a tall person 20 people down
they're blocking it down it sucks it's
just it's bad bad seat
so I know the seats and we're sitting in
those
and I'm doing my stare at the people I'm
like I don't get any love uh usually I
tell Matt that I'm coming the announcer
so I come say hi let me go down and
watch some shoot around before the game
a little bit
and uh but I didn't that when we got
there kind of late so I'm like I'm not
gonna bother him I'm just sitting our
seats we don't need anything from them
you know I mean so
I go and I'm
looking at everybody pissed and then
saying to Christine I go I but I'm over
it I'm so over that they are not like
why do I get no Philly love like I
should pick him up all the time and
there's murals of Kevin Hart in
Philadelphia
and I'm just giving my bitching my you
know Silly bitching on purpose be funny
almost
and then uh the water ice guy comes by
and I go uh
excuse me and this guy behind me like
shoves me and I'm like and he goes dude
and I'm on the screen no [__] you try me
because I look at what I smile and I
mean I do I go
I guess and I hear Matt cord and house
announcer he goes he goes oh is that him
right there is that him and I'm like
all right so I guess and then it
cuts to somebody else
uh is that him right there is that
another person is that his that and then
it it pulls out
on this a guy with a turban and a big
crazy beard he goes no there he is
everybody it's tonight's Schick razor
beard of the game
you thought they were gonna give you a
shot I was like I was like in that look
I was I was like when everybody else
just goes like ah I was like
on the bottom of the screen
and the punch to that whole thing even
more the final punch in the gut that's
why I always love the layered story of
like just when you think you're out of
it and over it here's one more
so I was like well you know what it's
cool look I get it I was a contestant
and [__] beard of the game but I think I
go Matt saw me there so he's like
he gave me a little bit of extra because
he did hit me on the camera a little bit
longer there I go that was Matt like
give me a little you know he can't get
approved to just shout me out so he gave
me like a little like so after the game
I go I go Matt Matt he turns around he
goes oh you came to the game tonight I
was like he didn't even [__]
recognize that it wasn't even a shout
out from him it was an absolute I was a
random Shick beard of the game
contestant
that's probably a pre-recorded message
of him going is that him is that it
might be it might be no I don't think so
I think he sits there right and does it
oh [__] dude God damn it that was so
funny no I think he just doesn't I think
I think what he's doing is he's just
looking at a little monitor right here
and going like that
and then he has to go like back over
here doing whatever the thing so he even
rides with me but man I wish there was
footage like archival footage of looking
they go and the guy goes look up there
is that him right there I go oh my oh my
my
I talked all that [__] and look at this
happening right now they're about to
give they're about to give him some love
you ever reach back everybody goes this
is how I want my poster to look
everybody
and I lost chickpeare to the game I was
one of the people like find any fat [__]
with a beard oh and the camera guy was
like there's a dummy listener
dude this has been a really fun episode
thank you so much for coming on thank
you for having me I've been wanting to
do it for a long time
um please plug everything again you're
special all of it bigjcomedy.com for all
my dates b-i-g-j-a-y comedy uh.com all
over the place running through the year
leading up to the special dog belly
coming out April 5th listening to the
bonfire on Faction talk series xm103
listen to Legion of skanks and STL on
gas digital Network all right one thing
I'm gonna ask you because I just forgot
is advice after everything we've talked
about advice you would give to your 16
year old self
I said almost what we said earlier I go
like smoke a little pot Maybe
almost like that maybe don't be so
tightly wound
because I wasn't like I was always like
a as a kid I was even like if I thought
about big crowds I was always like I
don't know I'm gonna get lost you know I
mean obviously they say live a little
more
that's why I say embrace it that's great
advice you're only young once that's the
thing I think I really because of
starting comedy so young too I gave up
youth I didn't have like it's a boohoo I
was in comedy clubs but it was a very
like my best friends and closest daily
friends were 20 years older than me guys
by that point you know I mean your
comedy clubs talking to the old vets you
know or the uh the guys that were in
their 30s when I was 19. so it was such
a directional shift and I'm like
do it see it more it's why I appreciate
guys like Ari shaffir and [__] my life
and there's a few other guys who do
things like when I go on the road with
Ari Bert Chrysler is another one of
those guys too it's like when we did
even like that summer tour where it's
designed for us all to hang out my
instinct still is like yeah come out and
we'll have like food and I'm gonna go
watch YouTube videos back in my bunk
with the thing closing the AC on and
just kind of not bother with anybody and
then I'll pop out and smoke a cigarette
and we'll have a good conversation but
they're like no that we only set up a a
disc golf course for us and I'm like and
my instinct is to go like yo you guys
have fun
are you I'm in Toronto with him you know
he's like we're going we're going to go
out to eat I'm like let's just get food
and like watch a movie in the room or
something he's like we're going like the
we went to like one of those restaurants
where you can't they blind you and
everything's in the dark and I'm like
yeah I should expect I just don't and
I'm trying to get better so I'd say that
experience like life a little bit that's
[__] great advice
um and thank you again and thank you
guys as well Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]